before I head on over to the Samsung
station a bit we get Danny go to our
back here but we're finishing on a great
one so if any you guys are fans a killer
instinct we have the guys producing
killer instinct season 2 which is like
the next additional bit of content for
the free play game so welcome to the
stage already forgotten your name this
is awful door I'm still ahead nice to
meet you Thank You Remus Cameron listen
ever let's pretend this is our first
introduction ever is this Dave David
tell for people at home who may be used
to play killer instinct and I haven't
got back into it we know with a new game
explain how it'll work just free to play
yeah how's it go so killer instinct
launched with the original xbox one it
was like when the launch titles it
launched with six characters and they
kept adding content different game modes
more characters over the course of the
first season and then people responded
really really well to that stuff they
like the free-to-play nature of the game
they like to constant stream of content
and Microsoft want to keep it going
until I [ __ ] up another season of it so
we're working on eight more characters
right now you can buy them basically
everyone you can get them all at once in
one bundles if you want to try them
there's always like one free and
rotation at all times so your name is
sure you like the game you get basically
download like a sixty-dollar game for
free play with it for as long as you
want and then decide if you want to buy
it later it's pretty awesome so it's
kind of like very similar model to like
say an illegal agents person yeah we
very short amount of free character on
rotation that's great so is that was
that been someone you guys to be
thinking about for a long time and be
like well you know what well you know I
don't Microsoft's been wanting to get me
free to play for a long time I did happy
wars was kind of their first foray into
it on they've done some other stuff but
I think like this is the this game it
really makes a ton of sense for right
because there's this kind of established
fighting game community we know you know
they love the games they love and
they're a little reluctant to spend 60
bucks to try something brand-new right
and so this really gives them no excuse
not to go out and try brand new game and
you know maybe they love it maybe they
don't but they get to try it before they
know you know it's pretty awesome cool
we're going to dive into some of the
details of season 2 in just a bit but
remember if you're watching at home and
you've got some questions either throw
them down there in the gamespot chat or
you can tweet them directly at me at
Camp fraz Rob and I will throw them at
David and you can try and knock them out
there I don't know about the whole well
you can try well yeah way down there
right we'll give it a shot either's fine
man no promises yeah ok so let's let's
have a think about some of the like what
you bringing you there in season yeah so
I mean they're super cool thing about
like us take
on season two from double helix is like
they had the game they made was awesome
it was so fun mechanics were so since
the previous CD who is double helix was
worked on season one and then they got
bought by amazon and they couldn't work
out anymore yeah we have a lot of
fighting game stuff in our we've done a
lot stuff of Capcom did divekick
basically a really deep level fighting
games in the studio so kind of natural
to pair us up with it and its really
awesome when you can start with
something that's established and really
cool and then you just get to put more
awesome stuff on top of it it's like the
best sandwich you've ever had and that's
a pretty good say no but imagine that
right it's amazing sand when I'm there
you can bring it home and then put more
stuff on it you love from your own
kitchen perfect that's exactly what it's
like it's exactly what it is okay cool
so what kind of well tell me about some
of this additional stuff your precious
sandwich so for season two what we're
showing here at e3 is we've got TJ combo
he's a throwback character from the
original ki series fans might remember
him we got TJ stage and we're also
saying there's going to be seven other
characters in season two that announcing
who they are yet or what they're doing
it teaching Calvin reaction there you go
so TJ's a rush down character it's got a
whole set of moves to get in close stay
close to do a lot of damage he's got the
tremor you can recapture what do you
basically what are the things in killer
instinct season one it was pretty easy
to get some characters in the air then
once you had him in the air was hard to
juggle more that you couldn't really do
much with them so TJ's got this regional
mechanic where we got to keep a combo
going once and campers airborne it's
tons of fun so perfect example right
there yes oh we got some more characters
not talking about all the other ones yet
we're still trying to decide like what
do you want to do how will we make them
like awesome put our own stamp on it
right and so in addition to that we got
more game modes more stages improvements
to online the whole ton of stuff is
gonna be awesome lets us watch that
again actually cuz I was over quite
quick in that it was a whole pack I
could watch that all day I got nowhere
to go see em yes with tj's like he's a
really simple character to play to he's
kind of like um saberwolf in that he's
like not super execution heavy he's
basically a left-right up-down character
in the joystick you don't need to do any
crazy 720 twist on the stick or anything
he's really simple to play but he's
super super fun and rewarding so he's
got his signature moves are he's got the
power line which we saw there to cancel
new a roll the power line can basically
closed a lot of difference really quick
there you saw the shadow tremor
shed and then we'll see if we get a
recapture here in a minute sales
recaptures when he grabs them and then
throws them back / shoulder and slams
him on the ground that that's as I
tackle if it's really fun to do so I'm
Kenny divekick I'm this one we're still
working i'm gonna bring dive kicking in
santee these characters away another
thing it slow early for that I don't
want to make any promises love it for me
ya know when this is a breakout
financial success and we're doing season
10 11 12 somewhere down the road all
right that's what I'm sure you can see
divekick mr. n they'll all make an
appearance i'm aren t it that's the iron
galaxy guaranteed all right you heard of
here first right die feeding by season
10 Susan testing some questions from the
chat so we have quite a few in here this
is great um Sonny 787 a says will you
keep updating and tweaking season 1
characters ? yeah for sure I mean
fighting games are all about balance and
you need to make sure that players play
well in this ecosystem like so we're
going to have to just by the nature of
adding more characters keep tweaking it
basically this is a community feedback
driven game Microsoft from day one has
been super super good about listening
the community hearing what they want
what they like what they don't like and
kind of tuning the game around that and
we're very much of the same mindset
there so yeah we're going to look as we
roll out new characters you know we're
going to be obscure people get mad Oh
your nerve Jago you did this to this guy
and we'll take it all in and make
adjustments as we need to coo coo all
right I think we've got another one here
as well ah sounds of questions coming in
the chat where'd it go I've marked it ok
here we go so I'm someone's wondering if
you might be bringing a damos back as a
way of showing off some of your
character so he says if you'll be able
to try your game why not go back two
days of demos to me it's become a lost
thing what you feel bad shadows I mean
in effect are free to play game the
whole game is the desert right right and
so for this one it's kind of like you
know there might be a way maybe oh I'd
like to try them all at once or whatever
but you'll get to see them online go
play some matches online with whoever's
available that week you'll get to see a
character find one you like and you know
either wait it out or plop down five
bucks cool guy see a question here
directly about and TJ comp was so how
did like exactly how did you go about
what did it take to redesign him for ya
so Microsoft had a lot of really good
thoughts on how they wanted so I'm team
of Microsoft's awesome they're super
like involved in the project there
really our pal Ken lob and those guys
right Kenseth won the original craters
of course he's got some thoughts about
otj should work right and so right in
beginning like about two months ago when
we really got going on this stuff we sat
down with all those guys like hey here's
what we think is essential to TJ and
then they kind of let us start with that
basic kind of massage it a little bit
and put our own tweaks on it and we were
making tweaks like right up until the
very bright until is billed we locks it
down like on friday you know changed me
they gonna put a little more
invincibility on the roll thanks for the
power line trimmer does a little more
knock down all that kind of stuff so
cool alrighty and again just you just
keep coming i'm just gonna keep shorter
man you this is great okay uh where was
it going okay will there be staged
Enders we're not talking about any game
features or new additions other than TJ
combo but you know that's something fans
always ask for and we listen to people
and what they want okay so am are you
guys gonna be working on kind of future
seasons as well as a is that the planet
you know right yeah right now we're just
focused on what's in front of us to get
these eight characters today new
characters um it's amazing as they can
be and super super fun and kind of put
our own stamp on ki I would love to do
this game forever I think it's really
fun but you know ultimately the fans
will decide how much of what we do okay
and Sam what when can people i should
get get home sighs dad why hey well here
is how are you all right well well
danice's dad this is officially gone off
the rails yeah yeah this happens he's
invade the Irish now I was always
evading he's sabotaging my set and we
could are there do-overs on this do we
do overs yeah I still alive or
anything's fine definitely not live God
to Daddy wire like John Drake said oh
[ __ ] John Drake the giant bomb scene
last night he said the yurt you were
working on a deal today you were signing
a deal yeah deals so here's the here's
the way John Drake thinks deals happen
John Drake thinks you show up in a
meeting at e3 and you tell someone about
a game idea and then they say yes and
they hand you one sheet and you sign it
and then you get money he thinks that's
how deals happen so I kind of
constructed this whole backstory but ya
know tomorrow I got like three deals i'm
going to pitch and sign all in one
meeting it's not this process that takes
months or maybe years right i do it in
the weekend because I'm that good and he
heated up with the spoon
so you sure you sure he just didn't like
screw up all three of you deals well he
doesn't know about the only one he knows
about is if I you know I can't you know
what are you gonna do right really
that's only one he could screw up dead
that's super hot that's incredible don't
be don't be like that Danny so you and
head Boone sign that off today is that
right no different at Boone it's a
different ID Boone yeah yeah it's ed
boon for Monticello it's not the same
that boom all right probably mom likes
apparent on my [ __ ] man their dad
talking about divekick to is it nope
we're just on my killer instinct oh yeah
Thank You fer we would have divekick by
wet season 10 there's got night when the
game killers when the game turns no
breakout success a financial runaway hit
I'm sure Microsoft will come begging for
us would die kick it so yeah we're in
there you enjoying your III so far it's
great man we got ki over the microsoft
booth we got eight stations of fun for
TJ we got divekick over the indie area
people get to play that on xbox for the
first time it's been amazing i'm super
super pumped yeah it's been really fun
are you gonna be I are you gonna spread
your love across all of the CBS family
video game websites I'm supposed to go
to join found another date tonight yeah
I should be nice and sober I should be
fine no problems it'll be uneventful I'm
sure there's gonna be a lot of suits at
tonight's show I hear see this that's a
moneymaker I think it happens sorry cap
you go that's funny you've kind of got
there the chemist I've seen it as the e3
dress code of the warmest car seat
jacket oh yeah well he he lives over
here in America now I'm back in the UK
so we've got quite a few thousand miles
between us so we just about make it work
I would see like I have to dress like
this to trick people into giving us
money I showed up how it normally works
we'd never get anything done no one
would pay is that why do have any money
cuz I'm no wearing a see Jess so that's
one thing one of the main reasons to the
boy factor also all right I gotta go by
myself see jacket but they told me to
where I stopped wearing shorts on live
streams as well we were banned from
where he shows a nice well you Pam down
too much you know we're in short no bad
loyal legs licking problem was a couple
of days earlier I fallen over drunk so
my legs are all bloody yeah so check so
they give a good image of gangs okay
cross well you know I'm not beautiful no
I think we have to wrap it up there but
thanks so much David Danny thank you for
your invasion what's the freedom okay
back tomorrow but this is your stage
that yeah I'm second all right just for
shits good what guys don't go anywhere
Danny will be in the coffee orange chair
I'll be somewhere else